foreign
[Music]
father always said that you are the more
artistic one
have you forgotten you're my twin
brother the Creator dealt us the same
hand of cards I just played mine better
you missed the funeral if only come for
the part that matters I will not share
the crown you will never wear it I've
dedicated my life to govern it and the
kingdom is on the precipice of
starvation the throne must be mine or
Millions will die have you forgotten
you're my twin brother we are born at
the same time my claim to the throne is
just as valid as yours well I'm sorry
you traveled all this way for nothing
brother I control the city Garrison I'll
have you exiled let us not forget the
power to settle this lays in the palm of
our hands
brother here in this holy house in front
of our father and the Creator themselves
for the crown the throne and the lives
of millions under its rule I challenge
you you fool you know not what you do I
challenge you to rock paper cross please
have you gone insane brother you project
such confidence and yet your eye Quivers
I know you too well but if I can read
you so clearly then how can I win if I
can read the slightest detail on your
face you can read mine we're brothers we
think we're different but on the seabed
of instinct where like weak sunlight
rays of thought are unable to pierce we
are the same you will predict my every
move
[Music]
poor brother I can sense your fear we
have spent every day of our lives
together you wore an open book to me it
will be trivial to defeat you thanks to
my ancient technique I can already feel
him in my mind the moment I pick my move
he'll know for the good of the Kingdom I
must win
one
sir is obvious when I think about it but
it terrifies me
is my mind I must have no mind I must
eliminate all thoughts three yes if I
never make a decision he will never be
able to protect me it's
perfect father you'd be proud
shoot
foreign
[Music]
it appears we even share similarities in
holy combat no matter the strategy holds
onward as planned
one two three shoot
again does he know my strategy two
stones in a row what are the chances did
he steal my notes did he follow me into
the archives no
stay the course don't change a thing the
moment you let a thought enter your head
you lose again one two three shoot
my heart screams at me to change course
to throw paper and win but it must not
listen it's my plan too obvious to never
change the shape of my hand not a
conscious thought in my mind if I am to
be the master of this Kingdom I must
start by ruling my mind this strains my
will to its very limited
[Music]
outbursts father would be proud neither
Prince wavering in their resolve he
still watches us
silently
huh
it can't be
[Music]
a brother brother father you yes it was
me he challenged me to rock paper
crossblades and
[Music]
the crossed blades father lost his life
with the crossed blades the foolish old
man had no idea of my power and neither
do you brother father it's so obvious I
feel like a dollar for not seeing it
earlier we're twins bound to the same
ruts of the roadway of the cosmos
he will only throw Stone it's how he
defeated you and it's how he plans to
defeat me then now that I know his
secret ending this will be trivial
thank you for helping me see father
entire Kingdom and The Crown let's
finish this
[Music]
foreign
I don't know
[Music]
I have to admit there's a secret
forbidden knowledge that we have been
withholding to you because you're not
subscribed to our website we are
releasing a tutorial that walks you step
by step on how to do this effect all on
your own and the best part about it you
don't need to pay for any software or
fancy stuff to do this you only need
this special Forbidden Knowledge so hop
over to quarterdigital.com subscribe
there and check it out it's amazing and
it will blow your mind it's a cartoon
I'm an anime now